a portion of this episode is brought to
you by google one
[Music]
hello and welcome to your first day on
the job here at theorist hq we have all
sorts of fun
planned for you as you start working as
our newest insert job title here
before we begin your exciting theorist
adventure we are legally obligated to
tell you that by continuing this tape
you are implicitly entering a legal
agreement with theorist is no longer
liable for any injuries or in rare cases
premature deaths but following you or
your family coming from any or all of
the following paper cuts running with
scissors
you're still there great welcome to your
new job
oh and watch out for that thing that's
behind the tv
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we still think you're beautiful no
matter how long your mangled corpse has
been stuffed inside a robotic sheet
so if you've ever been on these channels
for even a fraction of a second chances
are that you know that we're big
fans of five nights at freddy's no no
not that sort of fan
put that thing away you put it back in
that heck closet where you came from but
in all seriousness being a
fan at this point is a bit of an
understatement game theory has gotten 45
episodes dedicated to the darn thing
heck in less than a year
food theory got an episode it is
practically a rite of passage for the
theorist channels at this point but what
about me
poor little underappreciated film theory
the middle child between the official
movies constant delays and other fnaffy
films like the banana splits in willy's
wonderland being
meh at best it seemed like there was
really no chance for the requisite film
theory
on animatronic horror set in a nostalgic
80s era restaurant franchise
but then i found the walton files a
combination animation live action
audio play horror mystery experience
here on youtube
created by the chilean animator martin
walls the events of the story which is
still ongoing and unfinished according
to its creator
obviously draws heavily from its fnaf
source material but it uses those
elements to tell a horrific tale in its
own fresh way
a tale where the biggest horror isn't
the immortal aubergine serial killer but
rather our own failings as human beings
but in order to get to that end result
you first need to piece it all together
true to form on a first watch all you're
gonna take away are a bunch of
disturbing images but if you dare to
look closer the real plot is hidden by
glitches reversed audio unlisted videos
and even the scariest place of them all
the youtube comments section so what is
the tale
hidden inside the redacted walton files
that my friends is what we aim to decode
at its core we're very much in the fnaf
tribute zone at least
first there is a chuck e cheese inspired
family restaurant with animatronic robot
mascots a yet
unspecified incident of 1974 that causes
it to be condemned and a legacy of
horrific possibly supernatural terrors
spinning off from all of it the
restaurant in question this time
bonds burgers which is said to have
operated in 1974 in brighton michigan
the hook a troop of robotic mascot
characters called the showstoppers which
include our title character bon bunny
boo
zoo the ring master shah the sheep billy
the clown and banny the
other rabbit because redundant so far
the canon storyline is spread out across
three main uploads made by a person
named anthony titled introductory tape
relocate project and bunny farm
we know this based on messages anthony
leaves in the description of each video
as he himself calls out each upload is
in fact a compilation of tapes ranging
from found footage to gameplay
recordings to training tapes for new
employees and right off the bat we're
presented with this
backwards text backwards text that when
flipped gives us this message
you finally start to remember
you finally start to remember that old
day they will look out for you soon so
already within minutes of this thing
starting we can tell that we're dealing
with a repressed memory or
amnesia plot but who or what is coming
for us
it's two minutes later when things get
real serious
[Music]
that nightmare fuel there is jack walton
one of the co-founders of bonds burgers
alongside his best
friend felix crankin were told later in
the series that they met in college in
1958 via their shared dream of building
a restaurant themed around robotic
mascots which
kind of feels like a weirdly specific
thing to have a shared dream about with
a random guy you met in college but hey
you do you
jack well apparently doing you means
putting his creepy pasta face in the
scariest place is imaginable
jack is everywhere across all these
tapes on a movie box on late night
television in your backpack we see a
missing poster appear on tv with jack's
face
but unfortunately the video is too low
quality to make out the details on the
bottom on their own
the sound design of this thing is just
horrific you would think that our clues
would end there but in a brilliant move
on the part of martin walls creator of
the series by turning on closed captions
we can see that jack has been missing
since june 11th 1974 the same year that
bond's burgers opened and then shortly
thereafter
closed coincidence i think not our
little bond cartoon tries to get some
light but in a flash we see a possessed
bond animatronic over a new character
named sophie dressed in every security
guard's favorite color
purple after the sophie jumpscare we cut
to live action found footage from
october 10th
1982 where we meet and immediately lose
our final new character from this first
video
brian stells a facility caretaker for
bunny smiles incorporated the parent
company of bonds burgers but he's not
going to a restaurant friends instead we
watch as he drives to a storage facility
that's buried deep in the woods
labeled canine and i can't find the
place i made it to the location
i think chris told me this place has
been working since
about his job is to test out the
animatronics
hmm alone in the woods in an abandoned
storage facility turning on bloody
animatronics i think we all know how
this one's gonna end
brian is chased into the forest by bond
only to get himself crunched leaving us
with the parting words quote he thought
i was her notice again the purple
uniform suspicious
and with that uplifting message the
first upload of the series
ends but the mystery continues you see
under the video is a pinned comment
written by an account named
the comment is well it looks like
someone tried typing it with their feet
a string of random letters and numbers
seemingly amounting to nothing but you
all know better because you all
are theorists you know that's gonna be a
code and indeed it is it's a text string
written in base64 which when translated
using an online decoder
gives us quote the first pieces of the
puzzle have been placed the puzzle is
far from a solution however be wary of
the hints that appear over time
one misdirection can throw off the
course of this puzzle forever psi
o5 noteworthy here is the name psi o5
which when translated back
in base64 is go figure k9 just like the
animatronic storage facility
and now things are really getting
suspicious going to his channel reveals
nothing but a ticking clock and a
promise of more puzzle pieces for those
who are patient and
speaking of patiently waiting for more
clues we'll be back with more walton
files clues here in a minute but first
it's time for a break to thank our
sponsor for this portion of today's
episode google
one who sent me go figure this old vhs
tape for the integration
hey you yes you there sitting on the
couch are your photos overflowing is
your cloud feeling crowded do you have a
mysterious facility buried in the woods
hiding your deepest darkest secrets
because you have nowhere else to put up
if any of those apply to you and let's
face it we've all been in at least one
of those situations
then you should consider google one the
paid membership that's designed to give
you expanded cloud storage for
protecting and preserving all your most
important memories google one's expanded
storage works across
gmail google photos and google drive
allowing you to continue living your
digital life to the fullest without
having to stop and make the hard
decisions of what to delete just to save
a few extra gigs
true story breaking from that vhs thing
for a second here we recently celebrated
our 10-year anniversary over on game
theory which meant a lot of
retrospectives and look-backs and as you
might imagine a decade's worth of
scripts videos and photos is a lot of
data but my google one two terabyte
subscription has allowed me to keep it
all
for all of these years i was able to
find my first editor emails in gmail
filled with hundreds of notes the first
photos on google photos of me starting
the channel back in new york the first
ever game theory script in google drive
with its last modification
back in 2011 at no point do i ever feel
like i have to slow down my real life to
maintain that digital life it's always
just getting backed up for me whenever i
need it to be
and that's honestly only if you're a
heavy storage user like me you don't
even have to be a google one subscriber
to start backing things up to the cloud
every google account comes with 15
gigabytes of storage
plenty of room to store all those
vacation photos happy family videos
email threads where you secretly ask the
co-founder of your animatronic burger
restaurant it also comes with a phone
backup tool which is helpful if you ever
lose or break phones and a storage
manager where you can easily sort and
delete files by size with google one you
no longer have to go to dangerous
storage facilities alone in the woods to
revisit your loved ones
now their memories are right in your
hand you may go missing but all those
documents won't be thanks to google one
thanks to google one for sponsoring that
part of the video now back to the theory
so to recap we have bonsberger's
co-founder jack walton missing but
perhaps
still alive due to a message of let me
out of here on bonds tv in that first
video we have someone trying to regain
lost memories and someone or something
else trying to help those memories come
back
we also have two purple clad security
caretakers
dead brian from 1982 who was mistaken
for someone else and sophie could brian
have been mistaken for sophie maybe but
to know for sure we have to continue to
the second
and longer video titled walton files 2
relocate project
and again having closed captions on
gives us immediate clues that we
wouldn't have otherwise
dates for the four tapes that we're
about to watch which surprisingly are
all released around the same time
a training tape from july 2nd 1978 a
tech support tape from a few days later
july 9th
1978 found footage from three
technicians dated july 12th to the 14th
and then finally a jump forward to a
reprogramming tape from a month later
august also 1978. man isn't it nice when
franchises give you a clear
and thought-out timeline isn't that a
nice thing to have scott cawthon i hope
you're taking notes
oh sorry my allergies just kicked in
there i'm allergic to unclear and muddy
timelines
[Music]
from these tapes we start to fill in the
gap of time from the previous upload
with all these coming from 1978 we learn
what's happened since the closure of
bonds burgers and jack's disappearance
four years prior but also what
led to brian's death in 1982. we see
that in that time jack's partner felix
crankin completely took over the company
literally cropping out his former best
friend like you do with an ex-boyfriend
on social media the name relocate
project is his initiative to
well i'll let the text-to-speech bot
tell you the purpose of relocating them
in a new restaurant that would be opened
in a not so distant future
a pretty smart plan right a
not-so-distant future of 1982
as we see on this high fidelity drawing
of the restaurant so this
tells us that brian's death also in 1982
was a direct result of felix trying to
rebrand and reopen the bonds burger
franchise
and the film isn't subtle about how
great of a guy felix is let's give it up
for felix crankin
a man with not only a giant grain but
also a giant heart
hold on what what's that in the darkness
brighten it
sends shivers down my spine but there's
jack again almost as if he disagrees
with the video calling felix such a
smart and amazing guy the rest of the
tapes in this batch seem to be telling
us which souls possess which
animatronics we first see
banny the lady bunny who seems to be
possessed by a woman named susan
woodings based on a missing poster that
needs to be brightened in order to read
manny seems to be trapped as throughout
her section we see imagery of caged
rabbits and hear that
the rabbit is starving the rabbit is
starving
sounds like that bunny might be starving
i don't know just a hunch so
is susan starving or is this the
animatronic itself starving and needing
to feed on souls
it's unclear at this point but it does
seem to connect with a secret
final line that happens after this
episode's credits
waiting until the very very very end of
the video gives us this line
shadow man feeds me when lights go off
weird right it would seem like we have
another malevolent force at play in the
story or maybe the shadow man is a
caretaker of sorts for these
animatronics and the souls that are
contained inside either way it does seem
like we see the shadow man on this same
upload in the third tape the technical
support vhs
here shaw the sheep gives us a tour of
the facility leaving rooms and leaving
behind a dark figure
something that could easily be described
as a shadow man but that's not all the
creep factor in this tape in addition to
your standard creepy posters on the wall
and disturbing imagery we get
this piece of audio
right now more reverse sounds playing it
backwards we get this
rosemary would go to the restaurant
every night hoping that his beloved
husband would reappear after being
missing for weeks but no response until
one day she heard a voice saying i know
where she is rosie coming from the
backseat so it seems obvious that shaw
has the spirit of a woman named rosemary
inside
based on the fact that we hear talk of
her missing husband rosemary appears to
be jack's wife also meeting with an
untimely fate but the real detail to
call out here is the voice that leads
her backstage before she gets stuffed
using a shorter more casual name like
rosie she's
actively being lured back there by
someone who knows who she is
we hear later that bond the bunny is the
one who will fix you
so could it be that bon was also the one
luring her into the back or was it the
shadow man in any case it's yet
another confirmed victim of the
restaurant chain and yet another
animatronic identity confirmed which
leads us to the last tape of the bunch
in which three employees spend a night
in the canine facility as they try to
reprogram the animatronics ashley parks
one of the three wanders off at night to
explore deeper into the facility
through her found footage we not only
meet a new animal friend
a grey rabbit that appears to be more
puppet than robot but we also get up
close and personal with billy the clown
which seems to be an older model
complete with a cassette player in his
stomach
and of course this being a horror series
ashley can't help herself she plays the
tape
only to hear this
charms rosemary a list of names and not
just
any names jack susan rosemary sophie
one character we know went missing two
we know are in animatronics and sophie
whose role is still unclear plus there's
a new name this time
charles could this be a list of souls
possessing our five animatronics or
since we suspect that rosemary and jack
were husband and wife are they instead
all related to each other it remains to
be seen at this point in the series
what doesn't remain a mystery though is
the fate of ashley who
like so many before her gets attacked by
bonn and put
into billy in a flash frame before the
video ends we're left with this chilling
message and text across the screen
of how their visit ended they left the
next day they thought ashley left early
but she was in the back doors
screaming as much as she can but no one
heard the screams the following days the
caretakers would complain about an awful
smell coming from the back doors company
decided to shut down the facility until
new advice the relocate project was
unsuccessful
ashley is still there but she's not
screaming anymore she saw something she
wasn't supposed to see
and now she's beautiful she's beautiful
she's beautiful
she's beautiful again just like rosemary
we have this repeated theme of beauty
that fusing with the robots
make you beautiful in some way and with
that we're through everything from the
first two canon walton files or are we
you see there's one other massive secret
in this video
a hidden code to find an unlisted video
on martin walls channel and it's hinted
at by everyone's favorite commenter
more puzzle pieces have been laid out
for you others are more significant than
others
two pieces are crucial to slowly
achieving the solution
find the pieces return them to me and
meet at the intersection
see you soon end quote and wouldn't you
know it but sure enough there's a
youtube link broken in two pieces hidden
at both the front and
back of the relocate project video
putting them together gives you access
to a secret video
lucky you where everything starts to
come together but that my friends is a
story for another day when we continue
dissecting the clues hidden in this
incredibly dense series so for today i'm
gonna have to leave it at that
three solved animatronics and a lot of
loose threads to tie up like who is
sophie
what happened to jack what is the shadow
man and seriously a burger restaurant
pizzeria i get but
burgers i don't know now you're pushing
my suspension to disbelief anyway what
you think should i keep going was that a
fun one well
maybe fun's the wrong word maybe
interesting compelling the cool thing
about this series is that it's able to
get dark in a way that fnaf really
can't or at least hasn't yet but this is
more visceral more raw
and to me as a result much more scary so
if you'd like to see more leave the
comment down below
walton i don't know why i asked you for
that specifically i thought it would be
kind of funny to see a bunch of
waltons down there but you know you can
just leave a comment of whatever and
heck make sure you subscribe because at
this point i
at least have to get through that secret
video in part three right right
well if you want to be notified of when
that video drops hitting the subscribe
button is the only way to do it and
until then remember it's all just a
theory
a film theory and sweet dreams